nein ich bin traurig begrenzt ist
geschlossen
das corona virus trifft freiberufler
besonders hart auch marianne schneider
kämpft um ihre existenz die 60 jährige
betreibt einen kosmetiksalon in konstanz
bild traf mariana am vorabend der
grenzschließung zwischen deutschland und
der schweiz
ich bin schockiert weil ab montag meine
schweizer kohle königs bekommen durch
die grenzschließung brechen der
geschäftsfrau die einnahmen weg denn die
kunden stornieren ihre termine
ich muss voraussehen bezahlung die
wohnung die miete dies nicht günstig in
konstanz ist bekannt dass sie
deutschland wovon sollen wir leben und
constanze von schweizer kunst und deutet
in der schweiz leben
ich bin schockiert und sehr ich bin
gerührt bis zum trainer ich möchte alle
seine hilfeschreie von ein geschäft
frauen die alleine sind ist und sap nie
von der schweizer wirtschaft und und ich
bekunde die uns einfach in konstanz mit
viel geld bringen vielleicht bringt es
ist ab morgen
habe kein jahren allerdings weiter geld
soll